Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Djihadisme, Sud global,
Occident,
le nouvel archipel mondial.
Incontestablement,
nous vivons un regain d'activité
du djihadisme mondial,
alors que l'on pensait en avoir fini
avec Daech, cet Etat islamique
qui fut défait militairement,
mais dont les ramifications
djihadistes demeurent
extrêmement inflammables.
Devons-nous nous préparer à vivre
avec ce djihadisme d'atmosphère,
selon l'expression judicieuse
de l'historien Gilles Kepel ?
Cette préoccupation géostratégique
s'est considérablement amplifiée
depuis le 7 octobre 2023
avec l'invasion terroriste
du sud d'Israël par le Hamas
et la riposte israélienne
contre le territoire gazaoui.
Quoi qu'en pensent les belles
consciences et les bonnes âmes
de l'avènement de la paix
universelle des nations,
le monde est
plus conflictualisé que jamais.
Il se retrouve clivé
dans un partage géostratégique
entre le bloc
des démocraties occidentales
et une constellation d'Etats
regroupant la Chine,
la Russie, l'Iran, entre autres,
et que l'on nomme aujourd'hui
le Sud global.
Bref, nous assistons
à un renforcement
de la polarisation politique
de la planète
entre régimes autoritaires
et démocraties libérales.
A ce sujet, on peut s'interroger
si le conflit en Ukraine
et celui du Hamas en Israël
puis à Gaza
ne relèvent pas d'une même guerre.
Au même moment,
l'Europe est le théâtre
d'assassinats terroristes
perpétrés par la mouvance islamiste
très présente sur les réseaux
sociaux en ravivant
qui les plaies du colonialisme,
qui les plaies de l'indigénisme,
de l'antisémitisme
et de la haine universelle
des valeurs héritées des Lumières.
Doit-on en conclure
que le djihadisme veut la peau
de la civilisation des Lumières ?
Et si c'était le cas,
à quelles fins idéologiques,
religieuses et sociétales ?
Pour tenter d'y répondre,
je vous présente mes invités.
Benoît d'Aboville,
vous êtes diplomate,
ancien ambassadeur auprès de l'OTAN.
Hakim El Karoui, vous êtes
consultant et essayiste. Florence
Bergeaud-Blackler,
vous êtes docteure en anthropologie
et chargée de recherche au CNRS.
Patrick Kessel, vous êtes
journaliste
et ancien grand maître
du Grand Orient
de France.
Des attentats du 11 septembre 2001
à New York
au khalifat islamique de Daech,
défait aujourd'hui,
aux attentats en Europe,
à la guerre du 7 octobre
2023, déclenchée par le Hamas,
est-ce que vous diriez
que cet enchaînement conflictuel
résulte
d'une commune activité stratégique,
terroriste, guerrière,
d'un djihadisme mondial ?
Benoît d'Aboville.
-Je crois
qu'il faut apporter pas mal
de nuances au concept de Sud global,
parce que ce sont des pays
très différents,
qui ont des intérêts
mais qui ont trouvé
dans la revendication
contre, disons, l'Occident,
une cause commune qui est appuyée
par opportunisme
politique, notamment par M. Poutine,
mais aussi par les Chinois.
Alors, cela dit,
je crois qu'il faut éviter
de confondre cette...
cette querelle, en quelque sorte,
politique, qui occupe
véritablement toute la presse,
les débats aux Nations unies,
etc., avec, disons,
les problèmes, disons,
de différences culturelles
et surtout religieuses.
Vous vous souvenez des thèses
du politiste américain
Huntington, qui disait :
"Nous allons
vers une guerre de civilisation."
Moi, je crois que nous allons
vers un monde
tout à fait désordonné,
où il n'y a plus de... il n'y a plus
de puissance qui...
...mette de l'ordre dans le jardin
d'enfants multilatéral,
mais qui n'est pas...
...mais qui va
avec des conflits d'intérêts
de niveaux
très, très différents. Alors,
le djihadisme, c'est une... bon...
ça a aussi des nuances.
C'est d'abord un conflit
au Proche-Orient,
alors que la revendication,
disons, du Sud global,
elle est plutôt d'ordre économique,
politique et...
et donc pas tellement
sur le terrain des religions.
-Elle est pas civilisationnelle
dans la haine de l'Occident ?
-Non, mais la haine de l'Occident,
elle est liée,
non pas à l'attaque
contre l'Europe des Lumières
ou les Etats-Unis
interventionnistes,
elle est...
c'est une revendication de pouvoir.
Jusqu'à présent, nous n'avons
pas reçu dans la communauté
internationale l'audience
et surtout le poids
politique qui nous revient.
Aujourd'hui,
les pays du Sud représentent
dans le poids
de l'économie mondiale
quelque chose qui ne correspond pas
à leur poids
dans la diplomatie mondiale.
Les institutions internationales,
elles ont été organisées en 45.
Le monde a changé
depuis 45.
-Bien,
Hakim El Karoui, là-dessus.
-Alors, en fait,
il y a deux questions.
Il y a la question du djihadisme
et celle du Sud global.
Sur le djihadisme, j'apporterais
une nuance à ce que vous disiez.
Je crois que c'est
deux organisations différentes.
Al-Qaida 2001 et puis Daech.
On est dans un...
dans un système messianique.
On est dans un système
où le territoire compte assez peu.
Ce qui compte,
c'est le projet politique,
la vision idéologique
et construire une idéologie globale.
Le Hamas, c'est pas
un projet messianique. Le Hamas,
c'est un sujet d'abord territorial.
Avec une couche religieuse,
une couche idéologique,
une couche de haine.
Mais dans un cas, Daech, Al-Qaida,
on est sur une affirmation
idéologique d'abord,
dans l'autre cas, le Hamas, on est
sur une revendication territoriale
contre un ennemi très identifié
avec, et c'est nouveau,
les mêmes méthodes, très proches.
Mais il faut pas mettre
dans le même sac...
-Hakim El Karoui,
l'invasion du Hamas en Israël
s'est faite
avec un slogan très précis :
"Tuer des juifs".
-Ce que je vous dis, c'est que
la méthode et c'est ça
qui est nouveau dans le 7 octobre,
dans l'attaque terroriste
du 7 octobre,
la méthode est la même,
mais le projet politique,
la vision du monde
n'est pas la même.
Dans un cas, on
a un sujet avec le Hamas,
on a une problématique
qui est circonstanciée
à un territoire
et dans l'autre,
on a une vision messianique globale
téléologique et qui vise,
d'une certaine manière,
à la fin des temps.
Donc on parle
de deux choses très différentes.
Avec des méthodes proches.
-Pour vous,
Mme Bergeaud-Blackler ?
-Peut-être qu'on peut
commencer par définir
les termes. Djihad,
c'est la guerre sainte.
Elle se mène de plusieurs manières.
-Si je puis me permettre,
en arabe, djihad, il y a
plusieurs sens.
C'est la voie sur le chemin de Dieu,
pas seulement la guerre sainte.
-C'est beaucoup de choses,
mais aujourd'hui, on parle
de géopolitique, d'affrontements,
on parle de guerre sainte.
Donc le djihad, c'est la guerre
sainte menée soit militairement
avec les branches djihadistes
soit par le droit
ou contre les libertés,
par les libertés, on voit
cette citation de Erdogan.
Les démocraties contre elles-mêmes
d'une certaine manière
pour ensuite les conquérir.
Et donc
cette forme de djihad,
de pression psychologique,
de pression politique,
s'appelle l'islamisme légaliste.
Mais en réalité,
toutes ces branches djihadistes
ou islamisme légaliste
proviennent d'une seule
matrice,
qui est celle des Frères musulmans.
Les Frères musulmans eux-mêmes
ne sont pas nés comme ça,
ils sont nés
d'une réaction du monde musulman
à l'abolition du khalifat,
à la disparition
du khalifat, qui a été
un énorme traumatisme
dans le monde musulman.
Donc c'est important
d'avoir ce recul historique
pour essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passe
et notamment le Hamas, c'est
quoi ? C'est une réislamisation,
parce qu'en fait, le conflit
territorial a été islamisé
dans les années 20, 30,
par le mufti de Jérusalem
et puis,
il y a une réislamisation
à nouveau
de ce conflit avec l'arrivée
du Hamas, c'est-à-dire,
grosso modo, les années 80
qui ont vu, qui ont suivi
le triomphe de l'Etat islamique
iranien et qui a donné
une espèce de force
à tous les mouvements
de l'islam politique,
dont le Hamas, qui est
une branche des Frères musulmans,
mais qui, bien sûr, a une importance
particulière,
puisqu'il est un petit peu
les gardiens des lieux
saints de l'islam,
puisque Jérusalem est considéré
comme un lieu saint.
Donc c'est dans cette perspective-là
qu'il faut
poser le problème, je crois,
une perspective longue
de la revanche khalifale.
-Oui, Patrick Kessel,
sur ce continuum,
vous pensez que tout ça se...
Il y a une logique, une cohérence ?
-Je pense qu'il est difficile
de pas voir une continuité
dans ces comportements successifs.
La poudre a encore flambé
il y a pas très longtemps.
Donc c'est difficile de...
de considérer qu'on peut avec recul
avoir un point de vue objectif.
Donc je saurais pas
répondre à cette question.
Simplement, c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une phase
d'incontinuité,
et de méconnaissance
de ce qui peut advenir.
Et je vois aussi les...
les informations que nous pouvons
avoir de gens qui vivent
en territoire israélien
ou en territoire aujourd'hui
très partagé qu'on trouve
entre Israël
et d'autres régions
qui sont proches.
J'avoue qu'aujourd'hui...
J'avoue d'ailleurs trouver
une immense
médiocrité dans les commentaires
de mes confrères.
Je trouve que, dans l'ensemble,
les informations
qui sont données sont hachées
et qu'on ne sait pas trop
qui dit quoi dedans.
Où en est-on aujourd'hui ?
Je vois dans certains regards
un étonnement,
c'est vrai qu'on n'est
plus du tout dans une phase
de compréhension,
distance, conflictuelle,
je sais pas trop, j'aimerais bien
vous entendre aussi sur ce...
-Oui, mais l'information
est dans l'instantané, donc
les images encore plus que le reste.
-Sûrement.
-Mais...
-Oui ?
-On est face
à une situation
extrêmement complexe.
Je crois qu'on ne peut pas
considérer
que le Sud global...
...travaille avec l'islamisme.
L'islamisme peut ajouter,
mais le Sud global,
vous avez des gens
qui sont absolument anti-islam,
à commencer par les Chinois.
-Oui, mais personne ne leur reproche
ça.
-Oui, mais
dans l'efficacité...
-Même quand ils font
de l'épuration ethnique,
personne ne dit... On n'a jamais
vu la moindre manifestation,
pas plus en France qu'ailleurs.
Sur ce sujet-là.
-Il y a quelques...
Sur l'affaire des Ouïghours, il y a
quand même des gens qui protestent.
Mais vous n'avez aucune...
Les Russes et les Chinois
politiquement veulent changer
le système international.
Bon. Et donc,
ils s'appuient
sur ce qui leur paraît utile.
Mais Poutine,
il n'aime pas
du tout les islamistes.
La guerre en Tchétchénie,
c'est vraiment une offensive
contre l'islam.
-M. d'Aboville, encore récemment,
le régime de Poutine,
par exemple, a décidé
de s'attaquer aux valeurs
démocratiques en limitant
l'IVG, en pénalisant
le mouvement LGBT,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une attaque des valeurs.
-Que Poutine soit antidémocratique
et antidémocrate,
ça, on le sait malheureusement
depuis longtemps et on le voit
aujourd'hui.
Et il en fait un argument,
notamment pour s'appuyer
sur la droite en Europe.
Mais moi, je parlais
de la distinction
entre le Sud global
et son offensive
contre les structures
internationales,
une revendication de pouvoir,
alors, ce n'est pas Bandung,
ce n'est pas les non-alignés,
l'Arabie saoudite,
c'est pas un pays pauvre.
Et c'est un pays
qui n'a pas été colonisé.
Donc, si vous voulez, il y a
une très grande diversité
dans la notion du Sud global.
Je crois qu'il faut bien distinguer
entre les problèmes de l'islamisme
et les problèmes du Proche-Orient
et la question du Sud global,
qui est en réalité
le poids de l'Occident
dans les années qui viennent.
-Très bien.
On va distinguer
entre les différentes étapes.
Hakim El Karoui. Pour parler,
on va commencer par l'islamisme.
Si on prend certaines
réflexions qui datent
de plus d'un demi-siècle.
André Malraux considérait
que : "La violence
"de la pensée islamique",
je le cite,
"est le grand phénomène
de notre époque."
Jorge Semprun, un grand résistant,
considérait que l'islamisme est
le 3e totalitarisme du 20e siècle.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que l'offensive islamiste
d'aujourd'hui
est en continuité
par ses modes d'action
et ses particularités
avec cet islam politique,
dénoncé à la fois par André Malraux
et Jorge Semprun ?
Et dans ce cas,
à quoi l'attribuez-vous ?
A quoi attribuer cette permanence ?
Parce que c'est pas d'aujourd'hui.
Et des personnages que je cite
ne sont pas des extrémistes.
-Non, enfin, je pense que
personne n'a considéré
que l'islamisme était
une idéologie pacifique.
Donc ça fait longtemps
que la problématique est identifiée.
L'islamisme a une caractéristique,
c'est que ça mute.
Il y a à la fois des éléments qui
sont toujours les mêmes et en gros,
l'idéologie a été formalisée,
vous le disiez, il y a un siècle,
dans les années 20.
Il y a les Frères musulmans
en Egypte,
le mouvement des oulémas en Algérie.
Et donc, il y a une vision du monde
où il s'agit d'islamiser le monde,
d'islamiser
la lecture du monde.
C'est l'idéologie. Après,
il y a des moyens qui varient.
Il y a des moyens légaux,
plutôt ceux des Frères musulmans.
Il y a des moyens
que l'on dit piétistes,
ultrareligieux, ultraréactionnaires.
On parle peu du salafisme,
le salafisme a beaucoup
plus d'importance en France
que les Frères musulmans.
On est passés
à de nouvelles générations,
qui font un mélange des deux,
qui voient plus la différence
entre une tradition
plus politique des Frères
et une tradition
plus religieuse des salafistes.
Il y a eu les mouvements terroristes
et il y en a eu plusieurs.
On parlait d'Al-Qaida, de Daech,
c'est pas du tout
la même matrice idéologique.
Le Hamas, c'est encore différent.
Donc il y a une permanence,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une vision du monde,
des moyens d'action différents.
Il y a une temporalité
différente. Les problématiques
sont pas les mêmes.
A l'évidence, c'est
une idéologie violente, dangereuse.
Et puis, dans un certain nombre
de cas, subversive,
au sens où on sait pas très bien
où elle est.
Je dis que l'islamisme est
une idéologie plastique.
Elle s'adapte à son environnement.
Il faut faire attention,
on peut être musulman
et conservateur,
mais pas pour autant islamiste.
Donc, il faut, je pense,
dans le débat, l'analyse,
être assez prudent, parce qu'on a
vite fait de considérer
que tout musulman est un islamiste.
-Pour vous,
Mme Bergeaud-Blackler,
comment vous voyez
cet...
-Il faut que je précise
un peu d'où je parle.
Je suis anthropologue,
pas géopoliticienne,
pas politiste, pas essayiste.
La 1re fois que j'ai rencontré
les Frères musulmans,
c'était il y a 30 ans,
à la mosquée de Bordeaux,
où officie Tarek Oubrou.
Donc je connais assez bien
les Frères musulmans de l'intérieur,
j'ai pu suivre leur parcours,
leur influence aussi
sur les normativités
islamiques contemporaines
et il faut reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui,
les Frères musulmans,
qui sont héritiers,
pas seulement de la branche
d'Hassan el-Banna,
la branche arabe qui a donné
Hassan el-Banna, Sayyid Qutb
ou Youssef al-Qaradawi,
mais aussi la branche
indo-pakistanaise,
qui joue un rôle très important,
notamment sur le marché halal
des normativités
islamiques,
qui est celle de Maududi.
Et cette rencontre,
qui a été rendue possible
par le père de Tariq Ramadan,
donc Saïd Ramadan,
est aujourd'hui
ce que j'appelle le "frérisme",
qui est une idéologie
qui est plus large
que la seule application
des préceptes de la confrérie
qui est née il y a un siècle.
Donc, déjà, ça,
c'est une première chose.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
le frérisme est dominant,
est hégémonique
dans le paysage religieux
islamique français
et européen en général.
Le frérisme, c'est un salafisme.
Il y a plusieurs salafismes, mais
le frérisme est un des salafismes.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
le salafisme ?
C'est ceux qui se réfèrent
aux pieux anciens,
c'est-à-dire au prophète et
à ses compagnons, et qui en ont fait
un modèle d'imitation.
Ca, c'est vrai
aussi bien
des salafistes wahhabites,
dont, je pense, il a été question,
et aussi des Frères, qui sont...
Alors, la différence
entre les wahhabites
et les fréristes,
c'est que les wahhabites
sont des gens du texte,
ils travaillent le texte
et il leur faudrait
idéalement revenir
dans les pays musulmans,
faire la hijra,
alors que les Frères sont
des gens du texte et du contexte.
Donc ils travaillent le contexte
pour l'adapter au texte.
Ce que ne font pas les autres.
Et ça, c'est fondamental
comme différence.
Les Frères aujourd'hui en Europe
sont les premiers réformistes,
réformistes de la pensée théologique
et réformistes
du contexte.
Ce qu'ils veulent faire,
ils l'ont toujours dit d'ailleurs,
c'est islamiser la modernité.
Et moi, je traduis ça
par rendre la société
charia compatible.
Et aujourd'hui, pour être musulman
et avoir une approche
relativement libérale,
qui aurait dû d'ailleurs exister
en nombre beaucoup plus important
dans une société sécularisée
libérale,
c'est très difficile, parce que
le rôle des Frères musulmans,
c'est d'empêcher
la fitna dans la communauté
musulmane, c'est
de conduire le mouvement islamique,
c'est ce que Qaradawi disait,
il voulait créer un mouvement
islamique, qui donc serait composé
de l'ensemble des composantes du
paysage religieux,
des djihadistes aux plus libéraux,
pour les conduire vers le khalifat,
pour construire le khalifat.
C'est pas une chapelle, le frérisme,
c'est ce que moi j'appelle
un système
d'action.
-Oui.
Alors, Patrick Kessel,
dans ce grand Sud,
il y a pas que l'islamisme,
il y a des grandes puissances.
Comme la Chine, la Russie
et d'autres pays.
On laisse l'Iran de côté,
on va en parler après.
A votre avis, pourquoi la Chine,
la Russie et d'autres pays
activent cette notion grand Sud
pour s'opposer à l'Occident ? Est-ce
une revanche de civilisation ?
Pourquoi ils en veulent
à l'Occident ?
-C'est une bonne question.
-Oui, mais...
-Une bonne question.
Comment pourrais-je y répondre
d'un point de vue personnel ?
Non, mais nous assistons aujourd'hui
à une recomposition.
Si c'est ce que suggère ta question.
On est dans un contexte
qui s'est profondément modifié.
Et quand on parle aussi
avec des amis qui vivent en Afrique,
qui vivent au Proche-Orient,
c'est sûr que cette approche
est très différente de la nôtre.
En même temps,
il y a beaucoup d'incertitudes.
Il y a beaucoup d'inquiétude.
Je ne saurais pas répondre,
j'aimerais avoir les mains pleines
de vérités et dire :
voilà comment il faudrait faire,
comment il faut faire.
Simplement, il y a
une recomposition des territoires
et des cultures,
qui n'est pas au bout de ses peines.
-Vous voyez ça,
M. d'Aboville, comme une revanche
de civilisation ?
Ils estiment avoir été bridés ?
-Non,
c'est l'utilisation
de certains thèmes
politiques et idéologiques
pour retrouver un pouvoir
dont ils estiment
qu'ils ont été perdus.
Pour les Chinois, c'est très simple,
ils considèrent qu'ils étaient une
grande civilisation et qu'ils ont
perdu le pouvoir international.
Ils sont membres du Conseil
de Sécurité, mais, disons
au cours des 50 dernières années,
ils n'ont pas joué le rôle
qu'ils estiment devoir être le leur.
-Mais quel rôle ?
-Leur rôle,
c'est d'être une
des trois puissances mondiales.
-Ils le sont.
Ils sont même la 2e puissance.
-Oui, mais c'est récent,
parce qu'ils ont fait
un effort extraordinaire
de développement économique
et maintenant, ils disent,
on n'est plus
dans le monde de 45. Et donc,
il faut le changer.
Poutine, pour des raisons
opportunistes, s'est rallié à ça.
Mais, si vous voulez, entre...
...leurs différentes recherches
de pouvoir,
il y a beaucoup de nuances.
J'étais très intéressé
par les différentes nuances
que vous avez mentionnées
sur les courants islamistes.
Mais vous constatez
qu'ils sont appuyés au Proche-Orient
par des puissances qui elles-mêmes
s'opposent entre elles.
L'Arabie saoudite ou l'Iran
ont des clientèles très différentes.
-Est-ce que
vous accordez...
-Regardez la situation
entre le Liban et la Syrie,
c'est véritablement... Ils ont
des patrons qui sont différents,
mais qui,
pour des raisons conjoncturelles,
qui durent ou qui ne dureront pas,
aboutissent à ce qu'il y ait
des protections, de l'argent,
des armes, qui vont aux différents
acteurs, qui sont...
qui profitent
du désordre moyen-oriental.
-Alors, Hakim El Karaoui, là-dessus
et aussi sur la question de l'Iran,
est-ce que vous croyez
que le schisme
entre sunnites et chiites
soit une réalité aujourd'hui ?
J'ai... j'ai entendu
des diplomates saoudiens s'inquiéter
d'une revendication iranienne
sur les lieux saints, autrement dit,
ça reviendrait
à un conflit un peu historique
qui date de plusieurs siècles.
A votre avis, qu'est-ce que cherche
l'Iran aujourd'hui,
au-delà du conflit
au Moyen-Orient avec le Hamas,
le Hezbollah, les Houtis,
mais quelle est sa stratégie
aujourd'hui ? Au-delà
de son opposition à Israël ?
-C'est moins l'Iran
que le régime iranien.
L'Iran, vous savez, le régime,
il a perdu sa population
depuis un certain temps.
Et notamment ses femmes,
ce qu'on voit depuis deux ans.
Le régime iranien,
sa stratégie est assez simple,
il est dans un mode défensif.
Il essaie d'exister,
de se maintenir
au pouvoir coûte que coûte
avec une dimension idéologique
qui est toujours
présente dans le discours,
mais maintenant,
on parle souvent d'intérêts,
d'intérêts personnels,
d'intérêts des Pasdarans,
etc. Et comment il essaie
de se maintenir au pouvoir ?
En créant des problèmes
dans tout son environnement,
en étant agressif
pour essayer de construire
une sorte de glacis protecteur.
Et donc, c'est en Irak, en Syrie,
au Liban, au Yémen, tout autour
de son adversaire régional,
qui est l'adversaire saoudien
et puis, il y a son adversaire
mondial que sont les Etats-Unis.
Mais les Iraniens ont perdu
leur vocation messianique.
Ils l'ont perdue
depuis 40 ans,
depuis la guerre contre l'Irak,
qui s'est soldée
par une sorte de match nul,
mais qui les a
considérablement affaiblis.
La révolution islamique mondiale,
c'était surtout les wahhabites.
C'est eux qui ont wahhabisé
d'abord les musulmans immigrés
en Arabie saoudite
et qui ensuite ont wahhabisé
les Egyptiens, les Maghrébins,
et puis le salafisme est
arrivé en France,
il est arrivé par les Maghrébins.
Donc il faut laisser à l'Iran
sa juste place.
Et puis, on disait
il y a quelques années,
Gilles Kepel disait ça,
il y a l'axe chiite
contre le croissant chiite,
contre les accords d'Abraham.
Donc les Iraniens,
les Turcs et les Qataris,
déjà, il y a des sunnites
et des chiites. Et puis, en face,
il y avait les Emiriens,
les Saoudiens et Israël.
C'était quand Trump
était au pouvoir.
Biden est arrivé au pouvoir et tout
ce petit monde s'est rabiboché.
Donc, il n'y a pas
de conflit idéologique
et religieux au Proche-Orient,
il y a
un conflit politique, un
conflit d'intérêts,
un conflit y compris de personnes,
qui veulent rester au pouvoir
et qui veulent dominer la région.
Mais il faut pas tomber
dans le piège de leurs discours.
C'est souvent des paravents.
-Il y a pas que les discours.
Si on prend le conflit,
Mme Bergeaud-Blackler,
le conflit, le dernier conflit,
que ce soit
à travers le Hamas
ou le Hezbollah ou les Houtis,
quelle place vous attribuez à l'Iran
dans cette conflictualité à la fois
moyen-orientale et mondiale,
puisqu'ils arment en partie
l'armée russe
contre l'Ukraine ?
-Je crois qu'il faut...
Alors, ça, c'est le problème
de l'approche politique
et politiste en général,
c'est de considérer
que les êtres humains sont des êtres
assoiffés de pouvoir
et qu'il n'y a rien d'autre.
Evidemment, nous,
les anthropologues,
on considère qu'il y a aussi
d'autres dimensions,
des dimensions symboliques,
religieuses,
très importantes à comprendre.
Donc c'est pas étonnant
qu'on trouve les politistes
s'intéresser particulièrement
aux Etats-nations.
Pour eux, ils sont dans...
Ils essaient de comprendre
les logiques qui habitent
les conflits entre Etats-nations.
Le problème, c'est qu'on est
dans un monde mondialisé, qu'il y a
des réseaux sociaux. Aujourd'hui,
ce qui se passe en Israël,
on le connaît immédiatement,
ça produit des manifestations
partout en Europe.
Donc, il faut penser, il faut
se décaler et il faut comprendre
que les Etats-nations
aujourd'hui sont tenus
par des forces globalisées,
nécessairement,
ça s'appelle les réseaux sociaux.
Et donc, ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
avec le Hamas et Israël,
c'est une mondialisation
du conflit israélo-arabe,
sur lequel appuient ces réseaux
fréristes qui sont très puissants,
un peu partout sur les continents.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
Permettez-moi. Youssef al-Qaradawi,
quand il commence à penser en fait
son plan
pour les 30 prochaines années,
c'était il y a 30 ans,
qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
Il dit, il faut créer
une opinion publique mondiale.
C'était quand même avant les réseaux
sociaux, il était assez fort.
Et aujourd'hui, on voit que...
Qui appuie, qui tire aussi
un peu les ficelles
des conflits dans cette partie-là ?
Ce sont les réseaux sociaux,
ce sont les mosquées
de Grande-Bretagne,
c'est les manifestations
gigantesques,
c'est aussi les pressions
par le marché. BDS, par exemple.
Cette grande organisation,
qui veut boycotter
les produits israéliens,
a une incidence considérable
sur le conflit. Donc tout ça,
je pense qu'il faut le recomposer
et surtout prendre en considération
la dimension religieuse,
la dimension de la visée du khalifat
pour ces populations-là.
Ils rêvent d'une oumma
et quand on voit partout,
sur tous les continents,
des manifestations
qui disent "Allahu akbar",
ça veut dire quelque chose.
Il faut pas le ramener
systématiquement à des conflits
de pays, il y a une autre dimension.
La dimension
territoriale existe,
mais il y a autre chose qui se joue.
-M. d'Aboville.
-Je voulais simplement observer
que la recherche
d'une domination idéologique
mondiale, ça a été de tout temps.
Je veux dire,
Lénine avait un projet mondial.
Et donc... Mais c'était
au service d'ambitions
politiques
et nous retrouvons
avec l'instrumentalisation
des différents courants islamiques,
nous retrouvons exactement
quelque chose qui est éternel.
Et dans le cas du Proche-Orient,
il y a des ambitions territoriales
et il y a des jeux d'influence
qui sont d'ailleurs changeants.
Je pense, par exemple,
que les Etats-Unis ont fait
une erreur considérable
en attaquant l'Irak, qui était
un bouclier contre l'Iran.
C'était d'ailleurs l'argumentation
française.
Nous n'avons pas été écoutés
par les Etats-Unis, mais on a donné
un coup de pied occidental
dans la fourmilière au Moyen-Orient
et maintenant, on a les dérivations.
-Oui, Hakim El Karoui, là-dessus ?
-Oui, je pense,
enfin, l'oumma mondiale,
c'est le discours des islamistes,
mais c'est pas la vérité,
la réalité.
Vous allez dans les pays arabes,
pays musulmans,
l'identité nationale est très forte.
Les gens
quand ils manifestent en Tunisie
ils manifestent pas pour l'oumma
mondiale, ils manifestent
pour le droit des Palestiniens
qui est une sorte de mythologie
politique dans le monde arabe.
Ils sont très tunisiens.
Et les islamistes ont été
au pouvoir en Tunisie,
ils ont échoué lamentablement,
comme ils ont échoué partout
où ils ont été au pouvoir,
et les identités nationales
se sont construites,
ce qui empêche pas un discours
islamiste global,
mais le discours n'est pas
la réalité. Il faut pas tomber
dans le piège du discours.
-Il faut pas prendre les gens
pour des idiots non plus.
-C'est pas
parce qu'ils le disent
que c'est vrai.
-Il faut pas non plus les prendre
pour des idiots. Ils ont
aussi une parole. Ce sont
des sujets de l'histoire.
-Vous parliez du frérisme...
-Cette forme
d'arrogance ne fait pas
nos affaires.
-Chez les musulmans français,
vous disiez le frérisme...
-Le frérisme est une idéologie.
-Ca représente quelle part
des musulmans français ? 10 %, 20 %,
100 % ?
-Vous pouvez pas évaluer
la force d'une idéologie
sur une population.
Il y a des influences.
-J'ai fait une enquête
sur les musulmans, sur leurs idées,
leurs comportements,
leurs croyances, je suis arrivé
à une certaine répartition.
Ca m'intéresserait de savoir...
-C'est pas le lieu de discuter
de votre enquête.
-Pourquoi ?
Je ne comprends pas
ce qu'est le frérisme.
-Lisez mon livre.
-Je l'ai lu avec grand intérêt.
-On dirait pas.
En tout cas, ce que je pense,
c'est qu'il ne faut pas prendre les
Frères musulmans pour des idiots
ni l'oumma
pour le rêve des islamistes,
ce n'est pas
que le rêve des islamistes,
c'est en train de prendre
des formes... La violence du Hamas,
aujourd'hui,
cette violence terrible,
et pas seulement la violence,
mais aussi les cris de joie
qui l'accompagnent,
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on entend ?
On entend "Allahu Akbar",
on n'entend pas "Vive la Palestine".
Je veux dire,
il faut quand même prendre
au sérieux ces mouvements de fond
qui sont très anciens
et qui ont des résonances
historiques.
-La priorité
quand même pour le Hamas,
ce n'est pas la thématique
d'Israël, des colons,
plutôt que...
-Non, et ça, c'est intéressant,
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut lire
les grands idéologues
et Qaradawi a été
un grand idéologue pour le Hamas.
L'objectif, c'est vraiment
le temps religieux.
C'est l'espace religieux. Quand ils
disent, ils ne veulent pas négocier
avec Israël, ils veulent
qu'Israël disparaisse
et c'est clair dans leur charte.
Vous allez me dire,
il y a la 1re charte, la 2e charte,
il n'y a pas de 2e charte.
Le statut de ce qu'on appelle la 2e
charte n'est qu'un document,
c'est un document politique.
Quand on traduit.
Donc la charte, elle est restée
et la charte ne veut pas
de l'existence d'Israël.
La charte est
profondément antisémite
et son antisémitisme est
profondément ancré
dans le texte religieux.
On peut dire tout ce qu'on veut,
on peut dire, c'est juste
une instrumentalisation politique
du religieux,
mais à penser comme ça,
on est passé
complètement à côté de la force
de ces mouvements
et de leur influence aujourd'hui
sur les musulmans d'Europe.
-Ce qui est...
Je m'excuse, mais ce qui est
certain, c'est que les tentatives
à l'époque de Trump
des accords d'Abraham,
donc qui mettaient de côté
les Palestiniens,
ont en quelque sorte ranimé
l'espèce de solidarité
au Proche-Orient
sur le thème du...
sur le thème religieux.
Je pense
que les Occidentaux actuellement
sont sur la défensive,
notamment vis-à-vis des pays arabes,
mais pas seulement, puisqu'il y a
une instrumentalisation
chinoise, russe,
même les Indiens,
qui ne partagent pas les thèses
par définition chinoises,
puisqu'ils sont opposés,
mais même russes, qui jouent une
espèce de diplomatie opportuniste.
Tout ce Sud global
a des ambitions
de pouvoir international.
Mais ça passe pas nécessairement
par le Moyen-Orient
et ça passe pas nécessairement
par les idéologies.
-Alors, je voudrais,
bon, il y a des dissonances,
mais c'est le débat.
Mais Hakim El Karoui, je voudrais
partir d'une réflexion de Churchill,
qui disait : "Vous verrez
que les guerres des peuples seront
"autrement plus redoutables
"que les guerres des nations
et des Etats-nations."
On y est, non ?
Aujourd'hui ?
-Non, si vous regardez l'histoire,
les chiffres, le nombre de morts, en
fait, les guerres des Etats-nations
sont effroyablement
plus graves et plus létales
que les guerres des peuples
ou les guerres des idées.
S'il n'y a pas le bras armé
de l'Etat-nation,
le bras armé du système
militaire...
-On va pas rester
sur le Proche-Orient, on va aborder
d'autres sujets.
Mais manifestement, avec des Etats,
les problèmes se règlent,
tandis que, hors des Etats,
les problèmes ne se règlent pas.
-Je ne suis pas d'accord.
Les problèmes se règlent
par la guerre.
-Avec d'autres outils
d'analyse.
-Vous avez évoqué la violence
de Lénine, mais Lénine, aujourd'hui,
un historien comme Kershaw,
britannique,
qui est au-delà
de toute critique extrémiste,
il serait même plutôt à gauche,
il considère que
le pouvoir a été conquis
par la violence pour la violence.
-Le pouvoir,
il n'y a pas qu'à l'époque
de Lénine.
Napoléon a acquis le pouvoir
par un coup d'Etat,
qui était par définition
l'utilisation d'une violence
circonscrite, certes...
-Oui, mais ça revient
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui.
-Qui a aidé Israël
au moment de son indépendance ?
C'était l'Union soviétique
via les Tchèques, qui ont envoyé
des armes. Aujourd'hui,
la Russie s'allie
avec les anti-Israéliens.
Donc, si vous voulez,
on peut pas...
C'est pas idéologique.
C'est simplement
de l'opportunisme diplomatique.
-Bien.
-Il y a aucune idéologie.
-Bon, pour revenir un peu
dans le cadre de notre émission,
est-ce que vous pensez
que les valeurs démocratiques,
celles qui sont issues des Lumières,
est-ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
en danger ?
Et est-ce que ce Sud global,
au-delà de ses intérêts divers,
veut mettre en cause
les valeurs occidentales,
les valeurs des Lumières ?
Patrick Kessel.
-Difficile de répondre oui ou non,
parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans une situation de ce type.
Mais il est certain
qu'on est dans une phase
fort compliquée
et on voit très bien
comment se décompose
un certain nombre de valeurs
sur lesquelles ont été fondées
les principes républicains,
les Lumières,
des choses qui sont évidentes
quand on les ressasse
dans des articles,
à la télévision, ça paraît
évident et pourtant,
on sent bien que c'est pas du tout
évident en ce moment, c'est même
profondément menacé.
On est dans un contexte
où on voit bien
que les principes des Lumières
sont aujourd'hui fortement contestés
par des gens
qui ne se positionnent
pas clairement d'ailleurs
sur ces sujets.
Donc... C'était ça, la question ?
-La question est : est-ce que
les valeurs démocratiques
auxquelles nous sommes attachés,
qui régissent
le monde occidental, est-ce que
ces valeurs sont en danger ?
-Bien sûr.
-Si je puis me permettre.
-Oui, Hakim El Karoui ?
-Regardez ce qui se passe
aux Etats-Unis.
On a quand même eu aux Etats-Unis
une tentative de coup d'Etat
par le président sortant.
Pour moi, la plus grave
menace pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui,
à l'égale de la Russie,
c'est les Etats-Unis.
Les Etats-Unis eux-mêmes,
le retour de Trump
et au-delà du retour de Trump,
la polarisation du débat
entre la gauche woke qui devient
totalement irraisonnée,
la droite conservatrice
qui, à l'évidence, n'adhère plus aux
valeurs de la démocratie libérale.
C'est pas seulement le Sud global.
-Nous avons une contestation
de la démocratie en Europe même,
à l'intérieur de l'Union européenne,
qui s'est fondée
sur les valeurs occidentales
et sur les valeurs des Lumières,
je veux dire, quand même,
l'Union européenne,
c'était pas seulement
le libre marché économique,
c'était véritablement des valeurs.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons des gens
en Autriche, en Slovaquie,
aux Pays-Bas récemment,
en Hongrie et en Pologne
avec le gouvernement précédent,
qui contestent ouvertement
un certain nombre de valeurs
que nous considérons
comme essentielles.
Alors, pour réagir,
qu'est-ce que nous avons ?
Nous leur disons,
vous ne bénéficierez pas
des crédits de l'Union européenne.
Alors, c'est quand même
une question difficile
et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit efficace.
Et donc, nous avons,
alors, aux Etats-Unis,
nous avons une division
profonde du pays,
mais qui est accentuée
par le communautarisme,
mais qui n'est pas seulement
due au communautarisme.
Et je pense que cette division
de la société américaine,
elle est très périlleuse
pour la défense
de nos valeurs occidentales tout
simplement, parce que les Etats-Unis
ont représenté
pendant longtemps une espèce
de phare occidental.
Bon, aujourd'hui,
l'Occident, c'est pas seulement
les Etats-Unis,
c'est aussi l'Union européenne
et d'autres pays
sur d'autres continents
qui adhèrent, pas forcément
à notre système républicain
et aux formes institutionnelles
de nos valeurs,
mais qui partagent quand même
un certain nombre d'idées
qui sont proches,
disons, de l'héritage
des Lumières.
-Mme Bergeaud-Blackler, là-dessus.
-Rapidement.
D'abord, je ne connais pas
l'origine de cette expression,
le Sud global.
Je ne sais pas à quoi ça correspond.
-Vous savez,
c'est, j'allais dire, une création
médiatique. Voilà. Bon.
-Non, je m'excuse.
Ce sont les BRIC, qui étaient
des puissances économiques
qui montaient
qui ont décidé qu'elles n'étaient
pas bien représentées
dans le système international,
et puis, ensuite, ils ont voulu
globaliser et ils ont pris
des pays qui ne sont pas
des puissances économiques.
-C'est une réalité, voilà,
géostratégico-économique,
mais ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui,
c'est le mouvement décolonialiste.
Le mouvement décolonial,
qui est une partie du wokisme,
qui fait parler ce Sud global,
sans en être,
et qui joue un rôle très important
justement dans notre représentation
du monde avec les démocraties,
les non-démocraties,
enfin, un nouveau tiers-mondisme,
en réalité, qui fait que
ces mouvements antidémocratiques
de nos sociétés européennes,
riches et d'abondance,
aujourd'hui, se positionnent,
parlent au nom de ces nations-là.
Ce qui est
une autre forme d'arrogance.
Et on se retrouve effectivement
avec des analyses
qui sont produites par ce wokisme,
qui... qui dessinent un Sud dominé,
anti-Lumières et qui finit
par faire la promotion
de l'idéologie
comme celle de l'islamisme
dont on parlait,
qui sont profondément
antidémocratiques.
C'est pas que les pays du Sud
soient antidémocratiques
et soient contre le Nord,
c'est que, aussi,
il faut savoir qui parle du Sud
et est-ce
qu'on ne le fait pas parler.
-Je crois pas
que les décoloniaux
parlent beaucoup du Sud global,
qui parlent du Brésil,
qui parlent de l'Inde,
de l'Afrique du Sud,
de la Chine.
-Parce que vous connaissez pas
les décoloniaux.
-OK.
-En son temps,
on avait parlé d'un conflit
des civilisations. Bon, aujourd'hui,
comment on peut appréhender
ce qui se passe,
parce que, manifestement,
vous avez de nouvelles alliances
qui se créent
et est-ce que vous trouvez pas
que les Occidentaux sont là
à se culpabiliser,
à se flageller ?
Parce que, finalement, prendre
sa place dans le concert mondial,
on la prend par l'économie,
on la prend
par la création culturelle,
par les valeurs initiées
sur le plan politique
et donc...
-On la prend par la puissance.
-Et on la prend par la puissance.
-Et la puissance
supporte, encourage l'influence.
-Vous avez
cette manière de se flageller
aujourd'hui en disant,
on leur a pas laissé la place,
mais il y a pas à laisser la place.
Chacun prend la place...
-Moi, je pense que beaucoup de gens
ne se flagellent pas.
Je... Nous constatons
qu'il y a actuellement
l'idée
d'une guerre idéologique mondiale,
ça dérive des analyses
d'Huntington, etc.
Et qui était opposée à l'époque,
au même moment, à une autre
idéologie, c'était le triomphe
de la démocratie universelle.
Il faut quand même
se souvenir des débats actuels.
Et des gens, des Français
comme Pierre Hassner, par exemple,
avaient complètement démonté
déjà ces conceptions
et reconnaissaient,
comme Kissinger,
que c'est la puissance,
y compris militaire et économique,
qui finalement fait
pencher la bascule.
Et actuellement, qu'est-ce que
nous avons ? Nous avons
des Etats-Unis
qui jouent un rôle moindre,
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
s'engager autant dans le monde,
parce qu'ils ont eu des échecs.
L'Afghanistan,
le départ des forces américaines
d'Afghanistan, ça a été quand même
très impressionnant
pour les gens du Sud global.
Les Américains,
depuis le Vietnam,
ne veulent plus perdre
leurs jeunes dans des conflits.
Et donc, actuellement, nous avons...
Et l'Europe n'est pas
en mesure de compenser.
De jouer un rôle de rééquilibre.
Alors, elle le cherche.
Mais elle n'a pas les moyens.
En plus,
si vous ajoutez le vieillissement
démographique de l'Europe,
on n'a pas une force
qui est très active.
Mais je pense qu'il y a
une prise de conscience du fait
que nos valeurs sont menacées,
que la démocratie est menacée.
Cela dit, on ne va pas faire
comme l'avait proposé
Madeleine Albright,
une conférence des démocraties
et une organisation des démocraties.
Parce qu'il suffit de voir
qui on va inviter.
Est-ce que l'Inde,
aujourd'hui, qui est
plutôt pro-occidentale,
est une démocratie ?
Certainement pas avec M. Modi.
-Bien.
-J'ai été interrompue...
-Soyez un peu concise, il nous reste
très peu de temps, on va conclure.
-La fabrique
du décolonialisme aujourd'hui,
c'est les universités.
C'est tout à fait intéressant.
Ou les centres de recherche.
Nous, on a des étudiants
qui sont systématiquement opposés
à tout ce qui provient de l'Europe.
Donc ils se mettent
à la place des Indiens,
des Brésiliens, des Chinois, etc.
Ca, ces Etats
ne leur posent aucun problème,
même s'ils ont des pratiques
antidémocratiques.
C'est ça qui est intéressant.
Aujourd'hui, une bonne partie
de notre représentation du monde
est produite
par ces jeunes, ces étudiants,
qu'on appelle décoloniaux
ou wokistes.
-Vous parlez d'un noyautage.
Un mot là-dessus,
on conclut.
-Je pense qu'il faut quantifier.
Qu'il y ait des mouvements
minoritaires revendicatifs
ou revendicateurs, oui, évidemment
que ça existe, ça a toujours existé,
d'extrême gauche,
il y en a
de plus en plus d'extrême droite.
Le sujet,
c'est quel est l'équilibre,
et puis quelle est la dynamique.
Je pense pas qu'il faille
avoir peur outre mesure
des mouvements minoritaires.
Ce qui compte,
c'est la dynamique majoritaire
et je crois pas que les Occidentaux
se flagellent. Certains aimeraient
qu'ils le fassent,
en Occident, les décoloniaux.
Mais je vois aucun gouvernement
occidental aujourd'hui
qui se flagelle et qui en fait
un axe politique.
-Oui, un mot
pour conclure, Patrick Kessel ?
Il y a un malaise
des civilisations ?
Là-dessus, vous l'utiliserez plutôt
qu'un conflit de civilisations ?
-Je sais pas s'il y a
un malaise des civilisations,
il y a indéniablement un malaise
global
face auquel nos gouvernants,
d'où qu'ils soient,
ont bien du mal à prendre
le problème à bras le corps.
On sent aujourd'hui
les tergiversations, les besoins
de se justifier, les besoins de...
Tout ça, c'est du...
C'est de la poudre aux yeux.
On est dans un vide sidéral
en termes
de perspectives politiques.
-Voilà,
écoutez, puisque l'émission
arrive à son terme,
je voudrais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Alors, Mme Florence
Bergeaud-Blackler,
vous avez écrit "Le frérisme
"et ses réseaux, l'enquête",
avec une préface
de Gilles Kepel.
Mais en deux mots,
pour les gens qui n'ont pas
lu votre livre, vous avez voulu
montrer quoi ?
-Ce qu'est le frérisme,
cette idéologie plus puissante
qu'on ne le croit,
mais qu'on peut la combattre.
-Avec des racines historiques
et contemporaines.
-Tout à fait.
-Hakim El Karoui,
vous vous êtes penché là-dessus,
puisque vous avez écrit
"Les militants du djihad,
"portrait d'une génération".
Est-ce que
ce livre, que vous avez publié
il y a quelques années, vous pensez
qu'il a pris quelques rides,
aujourd'hui, ou vous le cosigneriez
aujourd'hui de la même manière ?
-Il portait sur la génération
des années 2010,
de la Syrie, les militants
djihadistes qui sont partis en Syrie
et ce qui s'est produit après,
en France, Charlie,
le Bataclan, etc.
Aujourd'hui, c'est plus exactement
les mêmes, les terroristes,
en France, hein, c'est plutôt
des individus isolés,
moins organisés, pas dirigés
par des forces extérieures.
Après, sur l'analyse, non.
L'intérêt de cette analyse
était d'être quantifiée.
C'était une analyse fondée
sur une base de données.
Donc on avait des grands nombres,
700 djihadistes français,
1500 au total.
Pour essayer de comprendre,
vu d'hélicoptère
d'une certaine manière,
les dynamiques sociales,
personnelles et d'engagement,
mais aussi idéologiques.
-Alors, Patrick Kessel,
"Marianne toujours", c'est
votre combat républicain d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui ?
-Ca veut dire Marianne toujours,
oui, ça veut dire
que si on feuillette les livres
de nos prédécesseurs,
on se rend compte que la question
demeure de la laïcité,
de la liberté de conscience,
et qu'on n'est pas sortis de ça
et que ceux qui ont voulu
en sortir
se sont grandement trompés.
On a besoin aujourd'hui de retrouver
des valeurs sûres...
-Et pour vous, c'est la laïcité
républicaine ? Pour simplifier ?
-Pour moi, c'est sans aucun doute,
je dirais,
le fondement d'un complément
pour être ensemble.
C'est-à-dire être capables
de vivre ensemble,
ça veut dire être capables
de se retrouver dans des valeurs,
dans des principes,
qui ne sont pas fondés sur la haine
de l'autre, sur l'affrontement,
auquel on assiste de plus en plus.
On le voit
avec la situation
au Proche-Orient.
Mais c'est véritablement
la nécessité aujourd'hui de trouver
un espace complémentaire,
de complémentarité,
et qui permette aujourd'hui
d'avancer sur ces sujets.
On n'est pas au bout de nos peines.
-Merci.
Benoît d'Aboville,
vous vouliez parler
d'un livre qui vous a marqué.
-Oui, Sylvie Kauffmann, journaliste
éditorialiste au Monde,
a publié un livre
tout à fait intéressant
dans le contexte actuel,
qui montre comment Poutine a,
en quelque sorte,
avancé ses pions,
en Géorgie d'abord,
en Ukraine aujourd'hui,
et que ceci a été fait avec une...
...avec une réaction européenne,
notamment de la part de Mme Merkel
et de Macron,
qui n'ont pas tout à fait
au bon moment
saisi les opportunités
où nous aurions pu réagir.
Et je trouve que c'est
très intéressant,
c'est très vivant.
Ce sont des témoignages
qu'elle a recueillis
et ça nous met véritablement
dans la politique,
active des Etats.
C'est pas du tout l'idéologie,
c'est véritablement la bataille
diplomatique
avec des avancées, des reculs
et nous avons
certainement perdu,
notamment en raison
de la puissance, disons,
du lobby pro-Poutine,
pro-allemand, pour des raisons
économiques en Allemagne,
nous avons quand même
perdu des années
et maintenant, on se retrouve
avec l'Ukraine et c'est un problème
très difficile pour nous tous,
car, si Poutine gagne,
nous perdons.
-Merci.
Je voudrais... Merci, Madame, merci,
Messieurs, d'avoir participé
à cette émission. Je voudrais
remercier notre équipe de LCP
qui a permis sa réalisation
et, avant de nous quitter,
je vous laisse
avec cette citation de Philippe
d'Iribarne :
"L'islam est dès l'origine
"un mouvement politico-religieux.
"Le fait
que les moeurs de l'Occident
"soient si peu marquées
"par des impératifs religieux
"tend à le faire regarder
globalement comme impie,
"rendant impie
toute allégeance à son égard."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA